suppose you asked the 11th century like
a portal opens to the 21st century in
the middle of say modern Russia you know
like what are your concerns about
fighting somebody from a thousand years
in the future
they might be like well you know what if
it's a wealthier country what if they
have more nights what if more of their
Knights are armored right
um and it you know getting through
they're just not going to get from their
nuclear weapons if they imagine that
Russia of the future has irresistibly
powerful sorcery
they'll get close to the truth it's not
absolutely irresistible and it's not
actually sorcery right they don't need
it can send the tank rolling through a
11th century Battlefield and you know
maybe if they see it coming they can dig
a pit trap but otherwise all the arrows
and lances are going to bounce off it
all day long it just rolls over the
horses right right it's talking about
orders of magnitude difference